Das ist unser Leben, wir
sind so aufgewachsen.
Man kennt nichts anderes.
* Dramatische Klaviermusik *
Man bekam schon ganz früh mit:
zuerst die Vorstellung,
dann alles andere.
Soit tu aimes ou tu n'aimes pas.
Es ist nicht immer alles
wunderschön und rosig.
Wir verkaufen Emotionen,
dann müssen wir sie
auch leben und zeigen.
Die Geschichte von Familie Knie
ist Liebe und Leidenschaft
für die Manege.
Aber auch seit über 100 Jahren
manch ein Drama und viel Krampf,
um den Zirkus an die nächsten
Generationen weitergeben zu können.
* Sanfte Klavier-
und Streichklänge *
2019 feiert Familie Knie
100 Jahre Nationalcircus.
Die Vorbereitungen beginnen
schon ein Jahr vorher -
mit dem Fototermin
für das Plakat.
Das ist der rote Rock mit dem Gilet
und den roten Stiefeln. Super.
Das finde ich super, das passt zum Logo.
Perfekt, wunderbar.
Sie ist schon etwas
mein Ebenbild.
Sie ist den ganzen
Tag im Zirkus.
Wenn sie etwas sieht,
das nicht gut ist,
wenn die Musik zu
laut oder leise ist,
leitet sie mir alles weiter.
Sie ist meine rechte Hand -
jetzt schon, mit sieben.
Wenn du nicht mehr kannst,
lässt du die Beine runter.
Du stehst ab, und wir
fangen noch mal an.
Komm, wir üben das hier, Schatz!
Nein, die andere Seite, Schatz.
Der hier.
Ja, genau, der. Schön an der Taille.
Ecco, così.
Schau! Schau mich an!
Guarda Papi!
Brava.
Ecco, così. Come è bella!
Vieni un pò più di fianco.
Es ist das Jubiläum des
Schweizer Nationalcircus.
Da wollen wir natürlich noch
etwas mehr bieten als sonst.
Das ist ja klar.
Bein noch mal runter, ja.
Sehr gut, ja.
- Aspetta, aspetta!
Eins, zwei, drei - und lächeln.
Das Bein gerade.
Super, ja, das andere auch.
Das ist schön. - Super!
Ja, schön. - Schön, super!
So muss es aussehen:
wie das legendäre Plakat
aus den 50er-Jahren.
Als Zirkusfamilie zu überleben
war schon immer ein Hochseilakt.
Auch in den Anfängen
der Dynastie.
Es war kein Zirkus, sondern
eine offene Arena.
D.h., auf dem Dorfplatz,
mitten im Dorf,
wurde eine Bühne aufgebaut.
Und auf der Bühne ...
Mit Orgeln und so
wurde Musik gemacht.
Auf der Bühne haben sie
eine Vorstellung gemacht.
Alles Mögliche:
akrobatisch, Clowns.
Dann gingen immer die Frauen
mit dem Blechteller herum.
Sie hatten schon ihre
Technik, und standen so lange
mit dem Blechteller vor den
Leuten, bis es etwas gegeben hat.
Kamen Knies mit ihren
Zirkuswagen ins Dorf,
kamen die Leute von weit
her, um zuzuschauen.
Zum Glück für die Dynastie
Knie liess sich auch
eine gewisse Margrit Lippuner dazu
überreden - von einer Schulfreundin.
Schön, dass du mich besuchst.
Soll ich uns einen Tee machen?
Nein! Weisst du, wer hier ist?
- Nein, wer?
Die Seiltänzer, Knies.
- Ja, und?
Knies! Kennst du die nicht?
- Doch, ich war auch schon dort.
Vier Brüder und einer
schöner als der andere.
Woher weisst du das? So
hoch oben wie die sind.
Den Jüngsten nennen sie
"den schönen Eugen".
Er ist nett, ich habe gestern alle
kennengelernt. Kommst du schauen?
Was jetzt, die Vorstellung oder die Brüder?
- Beides.
Ich weiss nicht. - Komm jetzt!
In der Frauenarbeitsschule haben wir
nicht einen anständigen Mann gesehen
und jetzt vier auf einmal. Das
müssen wir ausnützen. - Ja, schon.
Aber Vater sagt immer, denen
könne man nicht trauen.
Da täuscht er sich.
Die sind so tüchtig.
Die sind nicht nur
Seiltänzer und Clowns,
die schmeissen den ganzen Laden selbst.
Komm bitte mit! Bitte!
Also gut, ich komme mit.
- Was habt ihr vor?
Nichts, nichts.
- Etwas ... spazieren gehen.
Der Höhepunkt der Arenavorstellung
war immer das hohe Seil.
Dieses wurde immer von einem Haus
zum anderen gespannt, sehr hoch.
Dann haben sie dort oben auf dem
hohen Seil ihre Kunststücke gezeigt.
Das war die Spezialität
der Arena Knie.
Da, probier! - Was ist das?
Etwas Neumodisches, eine
Art gesponnener Zucker.
Wie die das wohl machen?
Und? Gut, oder? - Mhm.
Schau, es geht los!
* Lauter werdende
Trommelwirbel *
* Aufschrei *
Ich kann gar nicht hinsehen.
- Solltest du aber.
Sonst siehst du gar
nicht, wie schön er ist.
Wer wohl die Kostüme näht? Die
müssen ziemlich viel aushalten.
Das kostet sicher eine Menge.
- Darum verlangen sie Eintritt.
Bei den anderen geht Mutter
Knie mit dem Teller herum.
Sie nennen das Mantschen.
- Mantschen?
Lustig, gell, Mantschen?
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Das ist der älteste der
vier Brüder, Friedrich.
Soll ich ihn dir
nachher vorstellen?
* Der Trommelwirbel verklingt. *
* Jubel, Applaus *
Friedrich Knie war es gewohnt,
dass nach der Vorstellung einige -
wie man damals sagte -
Fräulein auf ihn warteten.
Aber so eine wie Margrit Lippuner
war ihm doch noch nie begegnet.
Herr Knie?
Ah! Sie sind schon wieder bei uns?
Freut mich.
Das ist meine Freundin,
Fräulein Lippuner. Herr Knie.
Freut mich. - Meinerseits.
Waren Sie in der Vorstellung?
- Ja, es war grossartig.
Fräulein Lippuner hat
ganz viele Fragen.
Die meisten wollen wissen, ob ich
so hoch oben keine Angst habe.
Was machen Sie, wenn
es plötzlich regnet?
Schauen, dass ich
nicht ausrutsche.
Aber das ist eine gute Frage.
Wir haben vor, ein
Zelt zu kaufen.
Dann können wir sogar
bei Hagel spielen.
Und Sie könnten schauen, dass
wirklich alle Zuschauer zahlen.
Sie müssten nicht mantschen.
- Das ist tatsächlich so.
Auch die Kostüme müssten weniger
aushalten.- Ja, das stimmt.
Aber Fräulein Lippuner möchte
auch wissen, wie es ist,
so hoch oben auf dem
Seil zu stehen.
Man hat natürlich
schon etwas Respekt.
Aber das ist nichts
gegen das Gefühl,
einem Fräulein gegenüberzustehen,
das ganz genau hinschaut.
Darf ich Sie auf einen kleinen
Rundgang einladen?- Gern.
Also, wenn es Ihnen nichts ausmacht.
- Ja.
Ich schau mal, wo Eugen ist.
Sein Rundgang mit Margrit Lippuner
dauerte das ganze Leben lang.
Aber das wusste Friedrich
Knie damals noch nicht.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Ein Jahr vor dem Jubiläum in St.
Gallen
holt Ivan am Morgen seinen
Grossvater Fredy ab.
Denn geprobt wird auch
während der Tournee.
Nonno!
Andiamo? - Andiamo, sì, ja.
Arbeiten. Hast du mir Kaffee gemacht?
- Ja.
Danke.
Heute Morgen bei der Probe musst
du gut aufpassen bei den Arabern.
Dass Ima nicht von
allein Walze macht.
Und Ishim auch. - Ishim auch.
Ich habe einen sehr
guten Draht zu Ivan.
Ich glaube schon, dass er
mich auch als Vorbild sieht.
Ich hoffe es auf jeden Fall.
Salut.
Guten Morgen.
Nachher, wenn er fertig ist.
Ich bin das erste Mal geritten,
bevor ich stehen konnte.
Ich habe immer von meinem
Grossvater gelernt.
Für mich war das wunderschön, denn
ich kenne die Erfahrung, die er hat.
Es ist eine Ehre,
von ihm zu lernen.
Alles rund um den Zirkus habe
ich von meinem Vater gelernt.
Das war eine sehr
strenge Schule.
Aber wenn man nicht
wirklich schuftet
oder keinen strengen Lehrer
hat, kommt man zu nichts.
Ich hatte das gleiche Kostüm, das
mein Vater in dem Alter hatte.
Damals war der Pagenschnitt
bei Jungen in.
Ich musste den genau gleichen
Pagenschnitt auch haben.
Es stank mir total, denn alle
meinten, ich sei ein Mädchen.
Früher ging man nicht
zimperlich um.
Ich beklage mich nicht,
das ist auch richtig so.
Mein Vater sagte immer: "Nein,
ich habe schöne, edle Pferde."
Deshalb sagte er immer "Pferd".
Rosse waren für ihn die
Arbeitspferde der Bauern.
Das ist ein alter Zopf und
ist bei uns so geblieben.
Obacht! Obacht!
Er hat in der Pferdedressur natürlich
eine neue Ära eingeläutet.
Man muss es haben oder
man hat es nicht.
Es ist eine Ausstrahlung,
ein Respekt.
Das Tier weiss genau:
"Ich muss gehorchen."
Und nicht aus Angst,
sondern rein aus Liebe.
Fredy senior war in der Manege
der Grand Seigneur der ...
Er war eine Erscheinung.
Mir lief es kalt
den Rücken runter,
wenn er in die Manege kam
und seine Pferde vorführte.
Dem eiferte ich nach, davon
lernte ich sehr viel.
Ohne den alten Fredy senior
gäbe es diesen Zirkus,
den es heute gibt, nicht.
Das ist meine Meinung.
Eine Zeit lang war
es natürlich so,
dass mein Vater etwas machte
mit den Pferden, dann ich.
Bei mir hiess es immer: "Ja, sehr gut!
Aber der Vater ..."
Weg, Cavaletti weg!
Lass sie Schritt gehen!
Allez, hoch! Jetzt, hoch!
Opal, Opal!
Malac, hier! - Opal, allez!
Wenn du "Ho" machst, musst du
es nicht so machen, sondern so.
Aber nicht die Peitsche hoch.
- Ich wollte ihn zur Seite treiben.
Ja, aber es ist verkehrt.
Allez, hoch, hoch, fest, Opal!
- Gut.
Es kann nichts
Schöneres passieren,
als zu erleben, dass
sie weitermachen.
Und weitermachen in meinem
Stil, wie ich es möchte.
Ich bin weit davon entfernt,
das zu übernehmen.
Klar will ich in die
Fussstapfen meines Grossvaters
und meiner Mutter treten,
weiterführen, was sie bisher gemacht
haben und weiter machen werden.
Und ich will mir beweisen, dass
ich genau wie meine Vorfahren
würdig bin, das zu übernehmen.
Komm, komm! - Morgen.
Pferde haben Vortritt bei uns.
Ob sie von links oder
von rechts kommen.
Und schon geht es weiter,
an den nächsten Spielort.
Sie müssen jetzt hier in St.
Gallen noch alle Wagen waschen,
damit wir sauber
nach Zürich kommen.
Heute ist Abbautag, die
Wagen werden eingepackt.
Man muss die Kinder
ausladen, das Baby.
Das ist momentan noch
nicht so eingespielt.
* Babyweinen *
Der kleine Maycol ist der neueste
Zuwachs in der Familie Knie.
Ciao Nonno!
Ciao Nonno, ciao Nonno!
Die siebte Zirkusgeneration.
Maycol ist mein Sohn,
er mein Enkel.
Ich muss mit Chanel hierbleiben,
wir haben noch eine Show.
Wenn so viele Traktoren fahren,
ist er besser aufgehoben
und in sehr guten Händen. Ich
gebe ihn nicht jedem ab.
Ich habe eine fantastische Nanny,
und meine beste Freundin fährt.
Dann ist er in besten
Händen, und es ist gut so.
Er ist schon ein richtiges
Zirkuskind, mein kleines Baby.
Während die ersten schon an den
neuen Spielort aufbrechen,
treten andere noch
einmal am alten auf.
Bevor er an den Eingang steht
und Programme verkauft,
verwandelt sich Peter
Wetzel in Clown Spidi.
Das war immer mein
Traum, schon als Junge.
D.h. also nicht irgendwie,
weil ich kleinwüchsig bin,
dass ich nur im
Zirkus arbeiten kann.
Wir haben auch andere Möglichkeiten,
können andere Berufe finden.
Und ich wollte das
schon als Junge.
Ich würde das Gleiche machen
mit 1,80 m wie mit 1,32 m.
Es wäre gleich herausgekommen.
Ich bin zwar immer lustig, aber der
Clown eher, wenn ich geschminkt bin.
Abgeschminkt bin ich
in meinem Privatleben.
Ja.
Es hat jeder mal schlechte Laune,
aber beim Clown sieht man das nicht.
Das ist das Innere.
* Fröhliche Zirkusmusik *
Eingang 3, dann links, bitte.
Guten Tag. Eingang 1 und 2 nach
rechts, 3 und 4 nach links, bitte.
Programmmagazine!
Auch Chanel macht sich für
ihren Auftritt bereit.
Und zwar selbst.
Poco davanti, genau. - Mmh!
Sonst schimpft Papi. Er will nicht,
dass sie sich zu stark schminkt.
* Spannungsgeladene
Musik, Applaus *
* Lautlos *
Mach es gut auf dieser Seite!
Du gibst das Zeichen
und gehst raus.
Schauen wir mal, wie es läuft!
* Liebliche Musik *
* Applaus *
Die Vorstellung läuft noch,
aber draussen wird schon alles
für die Weiterreise vorbereitet.
Jeder Griff muss sitzen.
Denn viel Zeit bleibt nicht,
bis der ganze Zirkus an den
nächsten Spielort geschleppt wird.
* Lachen, Jauchzer *
Früher wohnten die meisten Artisten
und auch wir, die Familie,
in den Wagen, in den
alten Zirkuswagen.
Diese wurden auf
die Bahn verladen.
Am Reisetag traf man sich am
Bahnhof, im Bahnhofbuffet.
Die hatten extra Verlängerung.
Man wartete, bis
die Züge fuhren.
Alle Artisten waren dort,
die Musiker waren dort,
die fingen an zu
spielen, zu musizieren.
Meine Mutter und andere
Artistenfrauen begannen zu singen.
Das war jedes Mal ein
Fest, ein Zusammenhalt.
Auch heute reisen die Artisten
manchmal noch mit dem Zug,
in ihren eigenen Waggons.
(Fredy Knie jun.) Es gibt
solche, die schlafen können,
und solche, die nicht
schlafen können.
Es ist das Gleiche, wie wenn
man mit dem Schlafwagen fährt.
Ich schlief als Kind sehr gut.
Knies hatten schon immer
ein unstetes Leben.
Ich fühle mich auch als fahrendes
Volk, ich bin nicht sesshaft.
Viele Leute hatten früher
Mühe mit dem fahrenden Volk.
Treten Sie ein!
Auch der Vater von
Margrit Lippuner.
Nehmen Sie Platz!
Soll ich etwas zu trinken bringen?
- Nein, ist nicht nötig.
Meine Tochter hat gesagt,
Sie seien Seiltänzer.
Ist das ein Beruf?
Damit verdient die Familie Knie
seit Generationen ihr Geld.
Also? Kein Beruf.
Doch.
- Sie haben keine Lehre gemacht.
Keinen Abschluss,
keine Meisterprüfung.
Die schwierigste, die es gibt:
Bei mir beurteilen täglich
Hunderte Leute, ob ich
meine Arbeit recht mache.
Bestehe ich diese Prüfung
nicht immer aufs Neue,
habe ich bald keine Arbeit mehr.
Eben, sage ich doch:
eine unsichere Sache.
Nicht gerade die Art Leute, die sich
ein Vater für seine Tochter wünscht.
Haben Sie je einem
Seiltänzer zugeschaut?
Ja. Ist schon lange her.
Die gehen einfach über ein Seil.
Heute hier, morgen dort.
Wissen Sie, wie viel
Training es braucht,
über ein Seil zu gehen,
sodass es einfach aussieht?
Wie viel Organisation, heute
hier, morgen dort zu spielen?
Die Arena aufzubauen?
Dass die Leute von uns wissen
und für die Vorstellung zahlen?
Ja, das ist sicher
aufwendiger, als man meint.
Ihr Zirkusleute habt dennoch
nicht den besten Ruf.
Wie die Korber oder
Pfannenflicker.
Es gibt in jedem Beruf
solche und solche.
Aber Knies wären nicht seit
Generationen erfolgreich tätig,
wenn wir nicht so tüchtig
geschäfteten wie jeder Handwerker.
Jetzt setzen Sie
sich, junger Mann.
Ich meinte ja nur ...
Wir wissen, dass die Vorstellungen
in der Arena keine Zukunft haben.
Deshalb kaufen wir ein Zelt.
Wozu? - Um darin aufzutreten.
Im Ausland ist das
schon gross in Mode.
Und wir machen es
in der Schweiz.
Eine Emmentaler Firma baut uns ein
Zweimastzelt für 3'000 Leute.
Und Sie glauben, so viele Leute
wollen ein paar Seiltänzer sehen?
Nein. Deshalb bieten wir noch
ganz andere Attraktionen.
Ich selbst habe begonnen, Hunde
und Pferde zu dressieren.
Sie werden sehen: Das
wird grossartig.
Wissen Sie, Herr Lippuner:
Wir denken an unsere Zukunft.
Wir sind vier Brüder, und jeder von
uns möchte eine Familie gründen.
Gritli?
* Glockenschläge *
Gritli!
Doch noch etwas zu trinken?
Ist gut.
Was?
Beim Mittagessen
stossen wir darauf an.
Jetzt wäre ich froh, wenn Sie mich
mit meiner Tochter allein lassen.
Es ist d e i n Leben, Kind.
Du bist alt genug, um zu
wissen, was du hier tust.
Wenn es dir dabei gut geht,
soll mich das freuen.
Aber wenn es dir nicht gut
geht unter diesem Zirkusvolk,
musst du ja nicht
meinen, ich helfe dir.
So.
Jetzt schauen wir, was deine
Mutter Gutes gekocht hat.
* Sanfte Streichklänge *
Margrit liess sich von ihrem
Vater nicht abhalten.
Ihre Beziehung zu Friedrich
ist das Fundament
der 100-jährigen Dynastie Knie.
Wenn man zurückschaut
auf die Familie Knie -
die Frauen haben da immer
eine grosse Rolle gespielt.
Denn die Familie Knie
hat immer Privatfrauen.
Jede Generation hat
Privatfrauen geheiratet.
Das ist ein Ausdruck.
"Sie kommen von privat."
Wir sind Zirkusleute,
sie sind privat.
Das ist ein Ausdruck,
der einfach steht.
Nicht aus dem Zirkus und
nicht aus dem Fach.
Und ich glaube, das war
irgendwie eine gute Mischung.
Margrit und Friedrich
heirateten nicht allein,
sondern gemeinsam mit
Friedrichs Bruder Rudolf,
der auch eine Private heiratete:
Sophie Griesser.
Doppelhochzeiten waren
sicher nicht so üblich.
Das war ein riesengrosser,
fast öffentlicher Anlass.
Die Familie Knie war sehr bedeutend,
eine Berühmtheit in Rapperswil.
Und heute würde man sagen,
es hatte doch auch mit einer
Marketingaktion zu tun.
Die haben das vielleicht sogar
aus Spargründen gemacht.
Eine Doppelhochzeit ist
billiger als zweimal eine.
Ja, sie mussten
aufs Geld schauen.
* Anschwellende,
glockige Klänge *
Jeden Mai gastiert der Zirkus Knie
einen ganzen Monat mitten in Zürich,
auf dem Sechseläutenplatz.
Früher war es immer gleich
nach dem Sechseläuten.
In der Woche danach
durfte der Knie drauf,
weil die Wiese schon kaputt
war vom Sechseläuten.
Das hat sich dann
so eingependelt.
Und es wollte auch
niemand anderes drauf.
Aber wenn man natürlich 100
Jahre lang im Frühling
immer auf einem Platz ist,
ist das schon eine
eingespielte Tradition.
Der Zirkus Knie ist eine
Institution in Zürich.
Einen Monat lang auf
dem Sechseläutenplatz.
Das war schon immer so.
Ausser im Krieg, als der
Platz ein Kartoffelfeld war.
Es gibt eine Menge Bilder
vom Knie auf diesem Platz.
(Originalkommentar) Schon fangen
Spezialisten und Arbeiter an,
das weite Viermastenzelt
aufzurichten.
Unter ihren geschickten
Hammerschlägen
bahnen sich die Pfähle einen
Weg durch den harten Boden.
Vor dem Krieg durften nur das
Sechseläuten, die Heilsarmee
und der Zirkus Knie
auf den Platz.
Und wir sind gar
nicht unglücklich,
dass die Bewilligung
grosszügig gegeben wurde.
Aber wir mussten auch kämpfen.
Das heisst nicht, dass wir immer
alles geschenkt bekommen.
Wir bekommen den Sechseläutenplatz
nicht, weil wir Knie heissen
oder blaue Augen haben.
Das ist verkehrt.
Wo ist der Gurt?
Nein, der grosse
Gurt, der grosse.
Oben. Oben!
Stopp!
Hai portato giù la 15/15?
Der Unterschied
hier in Zürich ist:
Normalerweise haben wir Pflöcke,
um das Zelt aufzustellen.
Hier gibt es fixe
Verankerungen im Boden.
Op! Fermo. Vai!
Oh!
Wir standen früher auch
auf dem Sechseläutenplatz
und haben dort
gespielt - mehrmals.
Für uns ist einfach schade, dass
wir nicht mehr drauf können.
Wir können finanziell
nicht mehr zahlen,
was dieser Platz heute kostet.
Das Risiko ist auch zu gross.
Wenn sie etwas kaputtmachen -
das seien so Marmorplatten -
wenn sie da etwas
beschädigen, dann ...
... können wir das
nicht mehr zahlen.
* Verspielte exotische Klänge *
Das Publikum sieht
nur die Manege.
Die Pailletten, die Kostüme,
die Artisten, das Lachen.
Aber der echte
Zirkus ist das hier.
Wir packen hier
alle gemeinsam an.
Wir arbeiten zusammen.
Und das verbindet uns als
Familie: die Arbeit.
Kannst du das aufschreiben, damit
wir es am Montag anschauen können?
Wir müssen Maycol fragen. Die
Masten sind mit Carnet raus.
Vielleicht müssen wir Banz
fragen, wo das Carnet ist.
Auch im Bürowagen sitzt jemand
aus der Familie am Steuer.
Die Leiterin der
Administration ist Doris Knie.
Mich nennt kaum jemand Doris.
Mich nennen alle Bimba. Und
das eigentlich seit immer.
"Bimba" ist italienisch und
heisst "kleines Mädchen".
Einmal kam ein Mitarbeiter zu
mir, weil er auf einem Zettel
den Namen Doris Knie gesehen hat.
Er fragte mich, wer das sei.
Denn eben: Ich bin Bimba.
Ich ziehe die Fäden im
Hintergrund und mache das,
was die Familie nicht gern macht.
Ich mache es sehr, sehr gern.
Okay, langsam schieben!
Auch ein wichtiger Teil des
Unternehmens ist ihr Bruder,
Franco junior.
Die Lüftungen hier
ziehen das Sägemehl an.
Es ist so fein und
staubig, wie Mehl.
Hier ist alles voller Staub,
die Linsen, die Geräte.
Deshalb muss man regelmässig putzen.
Das ist schon speziell bei uns.
Der Vater von Franco junior
und Doris ist Franco senior.
Er kommt heute zu Besuch.
Morgen! - Hey, salut, ciao!
Mein Vater war
technischer Direktor.
Als er abtrat, habe ich das ganze
Technische 1:1 übernommen.
Ich bin froh, dass meine
Schwester übernommen hat,
was er an Administration hatte.
Denn das war extrem viel.
Und es hat wohl immer
etwas darunter gelitten.
Ich bin 45 Jahre
lang mitgereist.
Jetzt bin ich in
Rapperswil im Kinderzoo.
Dort habe ich auch genug zu tun.
Nein, nein, das sollen
die Jungen machen -
die auch schon bald 40 sind.
Die Jungen!
Sie müssen irgendwann
selbst entscheiden
und Verantwortung übernehmen.
Das ist ganz wichtig.
Und ich sage immer: "Ihr
könnt auch Fehler machen."
Die haben wir früher
auch gemacht.
Nur nicht zweimal den
gleichen, das ist wichtig.
Hier sind unsere Ziegen drin.
Jede Generation macht
es etwas anders.
Irgendwann ist man froh, wenn
man seinen Weg gehen kann,
den Weg, den man richtig findet.
Verantwortung übernimmt auch
seine Cousine, Géraldine,
Tochter von Fredy junior.
Sie hat jetzt die Leitung übernommen
von Choreografie, Licht, Ton,
Auswahl der Artisten, alles.
Das macht sie alles.
Sie ist in meinen Fussstapfen,
und ich mische mich nicht ein.
Er würde nie sagen: "Nein, mach das nicht!
Spinnst du? Das geht nicht."
Sondern er sagt: "Ich
hätte es anders gemacht,
aber macht ihr es, wie ihr meint!"
Er ist nur Unterstützung.
Es kam vielleicht auch
schon vor, dass sie sagte:
"Ich will jetzt das."
Dann sage ich: "Ich
würde jetzt nicht."
Dann sagt sie: "Nein, ich will das.
Unbedingt."
Dann sage ich: "Also gut."
Dann gebe ich nach.
Aber dann muss sie
damit klarkommen.
Ab und zu gibt es auch ...
Diskussionen, Streit.
Das braucht es auch.
Aber wir haben es
immer geschafft,
das Ziel, das Unternehmen in
den Vordergrund zu stellen.
Sonst wären wir jetzt nicht schon
bei der achten Generation.
Schon die vier Brüder, die den
Nationalcircus 1919 gegründet haben,
mussten sich gegen die ältere
Generation durchsetzen.
Sie wollten nicht mehr in der
offenen Arena weitermachen,
mit der sie immer auf schönes
Wetter und ehrliche Zuschauer
angewiesen waren, sondern sie
wollten ein Zelt kaufen.
So ein Zelt zu kaufen ist eine sehr
teure und gewagte Angelegenheit.
Die vier Brüder Knie hatten
1919 eigentlich gar kein Geld,
um so ein Zelt zu kaufen.
Ihre Mutter, Marie Knie-Heim,
hätte die Finanzen zwar zur
Verfügung stellen können,
fand es aber einen
modernen Schnickschnack
und wollte keinen
roten Rappen geben.
Das Geld lag unter der Matratze.
Das stimmt. Es ist nicht
nur eine Redensart.
Sie rückte mit dem
Geld nicht heraus.
Sie hatte Schiss, dass es in die
Hose geht und das Geld flöten geht.
Die vier Brüder kauften
das Zelt trotzdem,
gegen den Willen der
Mutter und auf Pump.
Als sie das neue Zelt auf
der Schützenmatte in Bern
1919 zum ersten Mal aufbauten,
kamen ganz viele Leute schauen -
noch bevor der erste
Artist aufgetreten war.
So ein riesiges Zelt zu
sehen auf der Schützenmatte
war etwas ganz Spezielles.
Es war zwar nicht das erste Zelt,
das es in der Schweiz gegeben hat,
aber in der Tradition
sicher das bedeutendste.
Ziemlich viele Leute standen mit
offenen Augen und offenem Mund dort,
denn das Zelt fasste ca.
3'000 Leute.
Es war wirklich immens gross.
Es war eine Sensation, aber
auch ein Zeichen dafür,
dass Knies sich der
Zeit anpassen wollen.
* Wiehern *
* Hämmern *
Ich bin gespannt, wie
viele Leute heute kommen.
Ja, ich auch.
Margrit Lippuner und ihre Schwägerin
Sophie Griesser wussten ganz genau:
Ihre Männer haben sich mit
dem Kauf dieses Zelts
weit aus dem Fenster gelehnt -
vielleicht sogar etwas zu weit.
Voilà!
Doch, doch.
Wo kann man sich hinsetzen?
* Feine geheimnisvolle Klänge *
* Wiehern *
Nicht so bequem wie
bei euch im Hotel,
aber die tun's auch.
Wenn nicht genug Leute kommen,
ist sowieso fertig Hotel.
Dann sieht unsere
Wohnung etwa so aus.
Mit Glück können wir
uns Scheiben leisten.
Es war eine Bieridee, dieses
teure Zelt auf Pump zu kaufen!
Wie sollen wir das dem
Zeltbauer je zurückzahlen?
Mithilfe der Leute.
* Fröhliche Drehorgelmusik *
Und die Leute kamen
- viele Leute.
Fast zu viele Leute.
Zweimal Loge, bitte.
- Das macht 8 Fr.
Dreimal zweiter Platz.
- Gern. 7.50 Fr.
Danke.
Der nächste, bitte! - 2.50 Fr.
retour.
Ich bin mit Friedrich im Kegelklub.
- Der billigste Platz kostet 60 Rp.
Lass den doch rein! Hauptsache,
das Zelt wird voll.
Das macht Eindruck. - Marie schaut
in die Kasse, nicht ins Zelt.
60 Rp.
Dreimal reservierte Plätze.
Meier ist mein Name.
Jawohl. - Das Zelt ist voll.
Wie voll? - Einfach voll.
Wie bitte? Ähm ... 9 Fr.
Einen Moment, bitte.
Nur einen Moment Geduld.
* Entferntes Stimmengewirr *
Herr Cavallini?
(Mit italienischem Akzent) Signora
Knie, was kann ich für Sie machen?
Gehen Sie bitte raus zu
den Leuten und sagen Sie,
sie sollen etwas zusammenrücken!
- Come, io?
Aber wenn ich etwas sage,
lachen die Leute.- Umso besser!
Wenn sie meinen, es sei ein
Spiel, machen sie mit.
* Husten *
* Liebliche Spieldosenmusik *
* Lachen *
Vom Clown zum Platzanweiser.
Margrit war schon als junge
Frau geschäftstüchtig.
So. Der Nächste!
- Margrit, wir kommen nicht nach.
Doch, einer nach dem anderen.
- Nein, es sind zu viele!
* Drängelnde Rufe *
Zurücktreten, bitte!
- Wenn es denn geht.
Nicht drücken!
* Poltern, Läuten *
- Jesses Maria!
Immer mit der Ruhe! Es
hat Platz für alle.
Sophie, warte!
Sophie!
Wir hatten einen so
grossen Andrang,
dass wir vom Publikum
geschoben wurden.
Wir mussten unsere Kasse unter
die Arme nehmen und davoneilen.
Viel Publikum ist in den Zirkus
eingedrungen, ohne zu zahlen.
Die haben das nachher bezahlt.
Ja, das Kassenhäuschen ...
Das war für sie ein
Riesenerlebnis.
Dass sie es immer wieder erzählt
hat, war für sie persönlich
sicher eine Retourkutsche
an die Schwiegermutter.
Der grosse Andrang war
nicht nur in Bern,
sondern auch in den
nächsten Städten.
Es war ein Kassenschlager.
Die Knie-Söhne waren im
Gegensatz zu ihrer Mutter -
die ja gegen das Zelt war
- zwar optimistisch,
aber dass es so gut funktionieren
und so ein Renner werden würde,
damit hatten auch sie
nicht gerechnet.
Sie haben mit der grossen
Kelle angerichtet
und sie haben es geschafft:
Ende Saison konnten die vier Brüder
das ganze Zelt zurückzahlen.
Die grosse Kelle zückten
die vier auch beim Namen:
Schweizer Nationalcircus.
Vielleicht war es
etwas unbescheiden
oder in der Euphorie mit
einem so grossen Zelt.
Sie fanden: "Wir sind ein
nationales Ereignis."
1919 war es noch möglich, den
Namen quasi schützen zu lassen.
Und so konnten sie das
in die Neuzeit retten.
Der Name ist ein Segen
und ein Fluch zugleich.
Der Segen ist, dass die Leute
sagen: "Das ist unser Zirkus."
"Er gehört uns, er
gehört der Schweiz."
Der Fluch ist manchmal,
dass Leute auch sagen,
der Nationalcircus sei
vom Staat unterstützt,
die müssten sich
keine Sorgen machen.
Und das stimmt absolut nicht.
Wir kriegen keinen roten
Rappen vom Staat.
(Automatenstimme) Arrivederci.
Maycol und Géraldine
fahren nach Italien.
Dort wird das neue
Zelt zusammengenäht,
das das Publikum Familie Knie
zum Jubiläum schenken soll.
Ciao, ragazzi!
250'000 Fr. wollen Knies mit
einem Crowdfunding sammeln.
Eine Art modernes Mantschen.
Uns war bewusst, dass
gewisse Leute sagen würden:
"Haben die das nötig?
Müssen die betteln?"
Es ist überhaupt nicht so, dass wir
wirtschaftlich schlecht dastehen
und kein Geld für ein
neues Zelt haben.
Es ist eher eine Verbundenheit.
Wer nicht will, muss ja nicht.
Es soll sich niemand aufregen.
Géraldine, das ist die
Blache für vorne,
die sie angefertigt haben.
Weisst du, die, die
ums Zelt herumgeht.
Ah, ja.
Vorher war das Band nur so
breit, jetzt ist es breiter.
Ein neues Zelt hält plus,
minus zwölf Jahre.
Unser bisheriges ist jetzt
wirklich abgenutzt.
Dann sagten wir: Für
das 100-Jahr-Jubiläum
machen wir die ganze
Location brandneu.
* Friedliche Klänge *
Das Design für das neue
Zelt bleibt gleich,
aber wir ändern ein
paar Kleinigkeiten.
Für mich sind sie in der Zirkuswelt,
was Ronaldo im Fussball ist:
die Nummer 1.
Ich sage immer, mein Mann Maycol
ist ein Sechser im Lotto.
Er ist meine grosse Liebe, er
ist mein Seelenverwandter,
wir haben die gleiche
Leidenschaft
und wir geben alles für
dieses Unternehmen.
Er unterstützt Géraldine
natürlich sehr.
Und das ist auch richtig so.
Er ist schon etwas ein Zugpferd.
Er macht eigentlich alles: Er
kümmert sich um die Tiere,
er kümmert sich um
den Auf- und Abbau.
Er ist ein Multitalent und macht
eigentlich alles im Zirkus.
Viele, viele Zirkusse sind
neidisch auf ... auf ihn.
Dass wir ihn haben
und nicht sie.
Am Zirkusfestival von Moskau
wollen Fredy junior und
seine Frau Mary-José
ein paar Artisten treffen,
die bei der Jubiläumstournee
dabei sein sollen.
Natürlich sind die beiden
beruflich unterwegs.
Aber manchmal sind sie dann
auch ein ganz normales Ehepaar.
Komm! Schau nicht zu
viel in diese Fenster!
Man muss! So
wunderschöne Fenster.
Das ist eines der schönsten
Warenhäuser, die es gibt.
Warenhaus, Geschäft.
Er hat das überhaupt nicht gern.
Das ist nicht sein Ding.
Wenn sie shoppt,
gehe ich in den Zoo.
Für mich war es Liebe
auf den ersten Blick.
Schon als Teenager war
ich verliebt in ihn -
wenn man das so nennen kann.
Ich himmelte ihn an, wie
man einen Star anhimmelt.
Fredy hat mich schon
immer fasziniert.
* Fröhliche Zirkusmusik *
Die ganzen jungen Mädchen ...
Wir waren alle noch ledig,
und jede machte sich
etwas Hoffnungen.
Ich hatte nur an einem
Abend Zeit für den Zirkus.
Ich stand an der Kasse und
wollte unbedingt ein Billett.
Aber es war ausverkauft.
Das war mein grosses Glück.
Fredy und sein Bruder waren am
Buffet und haben das gesehen.
Sein Bruder kam zu mir
und fragte, was los sei.
Ich sagte, ich wolle in den Zirkus,
bekäme aber kein Billett mehr.
Dann stellte er für mich
einen Extrastuhl ins Zelt.
Das war meine Chance,
Fredy zu treffen.
Mein Bruder stellte
diesen Stuhl rein.
Dann hatten wir Vorstellung.
Dann erzählte er
in der Garderobe,
er habe eine aus Neuenburg
ohne Billett reingesetzt.
Sie sass dann natürlich zuvorderst,
und wir haben sie alle gesehen.
Sie war ja nicht unauffällig, sie
hatte damals ganz kurze Haare.
Das hatte damals
eigentlich niemand.
Sie als Model musste
die Haare so tragen.
Mein Bruder sagte:
"Ich sagte ihr ..."
Als wir jung waren, gingen
wir sehr oft ins Mascotte.
Er sagte: "Ich habe gesagt,
sie soll nachher mitkommen."
Ich sagte: "Ja, gut." Dort haben
wir uns näher kennengelernt.
Dann war der Kontakt
hergestellt.
Es war Schicksal.
Man weiss nicht, warum
es Klick macht.
Es hat einfach schnell
gefunkt, auf beiden Seiten.
Der Rote Platz in Moskau.
45 Jahre gehen die beiden schon
Seite an Seite durchs Leben.
Andere fotografieren auf
dem Roten Platz den Kreml,
aber sie sehen schon die
nächsten Attraktionen.
Das muss ich Maycol zeigen.
Weisst du, wie gefährlich
die dort oben leben?
* Treibende Klaviermusik *
Alle Festivals sind
für uns praktisch,
denn dort kommen die
Artisten zusammen.
Früher, als es keine Festivals
gab, musste man viel mehr reisen.
Jetzt sieht man sie an
verschiedenen Festivals zusammen.
Das ist für uns praktisch.
Es ist wie eine Messe.
An diesem Festival
zeigen Artisten
die ganze Vielfalt des
aktuellen Zirkusschaffens.
* Russische Durchsage *
* Rasante Popmusik *
* Jubel *
Bravo!
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Dima Sokolov und seine grosse Truppe
kommen mit auf die Jubiläumstournee.
Und natürlich möchte er,
dass es für alle Platz hat.
Wie viele Familien
seid ihr denn?
Sechs. - Sechs?
Yes, yes.
Du musst es mir aufschreiben:
wie viele Familien,
wie viele Frauen, wie viele Kinder.
- Es sind zwei Familien mehr.
Puh! Das müssen wir mit
Géraldine besprechen.
Wir haben viele Leute
nächstes Jahr.
* Zauberhafte Klaviermusik *
Fredy zieht es immer
wieder in die Manege.
Das ist der wichtigste Ort.
Hier wird in der Familie
Knie sogar geheiratet.
Wir wollten das im
Zirkuszelt machen.
Wir lieben die Manege.
Es war dann natürlich auch
ein riesiges Medienereignis.
Drei Viertel unseres Lebens findet
in der Öffentlichkeit statt.
Und wir teilen es auch gern
mit der Öffentlichkeit.
Das haben wir schon von den
Grossvätern und Vätern übernommen.
Es wurde uns immer
wieder eingetrichtert.
"Bleibt publikumsnah!"
Und ich glaube, das
ist ein gutes Rezept.
Als ich mit Fredys Grossmutter,
seinem Vater und seiner Mutter
im Wohnwagen war, war das
für mich am Anfang so:
"Ich träume, das kann
nicht wahr sein."
Ich glaube, sie hat sich
ziemlich schnell akklimatisiert.
Sie hat sich überhaupt
nicht geziert oder gesagt:
"Zu Hause habe ich
ein eigenes Bad."
Nein, es war für sie
so was von normal.
Damals war der Komfort
in unseren Wagen
natürlich noch viel
tiefer als jetzt.
Nix, da ist sie voll durch.
Sie hat nicht mit
der Wimper gezuckt.
Noch viel weniger Komfort hatte
Fredy juniors Grossmutter Margrit,
als sie als Private
in die Familie kam.
Findest du das Zirkusleben wirklich
so toll oder sagst du das nur?
Doch! Ich fühle
mich hier zu Hause.
Nur jonglieren kann
ich noch nicht.
Es ist schon sehr eng hier drin.
- Ja.
* Ein Hahn kräht. *
Und fliessendes Wasser
müsste es heute auch haben.
Stimmt, das wäre praktisch.
Hier draussen ist doch nach der
Vorstellung immer ein Radau.
Wie kannst du da schlafen?
- Nicht.
Möchtest du nicht auch lieber ins
Hotel wie Rudolf und ich? - Nein!
Dort hast du alles,
was du brauchst.
Auch Äquilibristen, Fakire
und einen dummen August?
Was? Nein. Wieso? Die
hast du ja hier.
Eben. Darum will ich
auch hierbleiben.
Denn mal brauchen sie mich, mal
brauche ich sie. - Ja, schon.
Weisst du, wir haben auch ein
wenig den Zirkus geheiratet.
* Bellen, Wiehern *
Es ist doch feudal:
Wir leben in jeder Schweizer
Stadt mitten im Zentrum.
Was ist denn das?
- Ein Tischtuch aus einer Aussteuer.
Ich will so etwas nicht
mehr hier sehen. Hier!
Was sollen die Leute denken? Familie
Knie sei etwas Mehrbesseres?
Ich wollte es etwas
schön machen.
Schön genug.
Es gibt zu essen.
So eine hat es im Hotel nicht.
Dort kannst du machen,
was du willst.
Hier nicht. - Eben.
* Unheilvolle Klaviermusik *
Es ist schon recht, denn
wenn die Leute denken,
es sei uns zu Kopf gestiegen, kommen
sie nicht mehr in den Zirkus.
Dann können wir zusammenpacken.
Es ist doch ganz wichtig, dass
die Leute uns auch schätzen.
Ich meine, wenn wir uns
anständig benehmen,
kommen die Leute
auch in den Zirkus.
Wären wir Querschläger, würden
sie sich eher überlegen,
ob sie hingehen
sollen oder nicht.
Damit die Leute auch im
Jubiläumsjahr in den Zirkus kommen,
veranstaltet Familie Knie schon
ein paar Monate vor Tourneestart
eine Pressekonferenz.
Ich werde Ihnen jetzt unser Deutsch-
schweizer Highlight präsentieren.
Das ist:
Giacobbo/Müller.
* Unverständlich *
Wir begrüssen das Risiko
von Familie Knie.
Mhm.
Wir geben uns Mühe, wir
werden pünktlich kommen,
aber jeweils auch
pünktlich wieder gehen.
* Applaus *
Da Viktor und ich schon immer
in verschiedenen Zusammenhängen
gearbeitet haben,
sind wir es gewohnt, uns
auf anderes einzustellen.
Ich kenne ihn einfach
noch nicht so gut.
Es gab eine Spezialsendung ...
- Mich kennst du noch nicht gut?
Nach all den ... - Den Zirkus!
Ah, okay.
- Dich kenne ich oft auch nicht.
Je länger, desto weniger.
- Ich bin auch froh.
Kabarettisten als Zugpferde -
das hat im Zirkus Knie schon
eine lange Tradition.
* Verspielte Xylophon-
und Trommelklänge *
Legendär: Emil 1977.
Auch wenn der Anfang
hart für ihn war.
Meine Eltern mochten
es gar nicht,
dass ich auf der Bühne
bin und Kabarett mache.
Dann wusste ich:
Jetzt muss ich meiner Mutter
sagen, dass ich zum Zirkus gehe.
Sie, die immer zu mir sagte:
"Aus dir wird sowieso nichts."
"Du landest höchstens
beim Zirkus."
Ich dachte, jetzt muss
ich meinen Eltern sagen,
dass ich wirklich
beim Zirkus lande.
Unter dem Motto "Knie mit Emil"
zeigen wir Ihnen ein komplett neues,
internationales Zirkusprogramm
mit Artisten, Clowns und
Tieren aus aller Welt.
* Applaus * Glace!
Ich habe Brombeeren,
Erdbeeren, Bodenbeeren.
* Lachen * Ich habe Camarel.
Ich habe Carlamel.
Ich habe Cam... Camarar...
...glace! * Lachen *
Ich erzählte niemandem,
was ich machen würde.
Erst etwa 14 Tage vor der
Premiere fragten sie,
ob wir mal zusammensitzen wollten,
was wir vorbereiten müssten.
Die haben sich nicht
speziell interessiert.
Was hängt hier nicht
alles herunter?
Haben sie gestern wieder
nicht aufgeräumt?
Oh, hier hat es ja ein Seil! Ha!
Wir könnten zusammen etwas
ausprobieren, es schaut niemand.
Mal schauen, ob wir
den Glaceverkauf
nicht etwas anders
organisieren könnten.
Wenn wir schon so ein Seil haben,
sollte das funktionieren. So.
Das Geld bereit machen!
* Lachen *
Die erste Glace, die
per Luftpost kommt.
Wenn ich am Seil
hing, hat man ...
Das ging über eine
Rolle nach hinten,
und hinten haben sie gezogen,
sodass ich etwas abhob.
Und beim Zuschauer liessen
sie es etwas runter,
dann berührte er das Sägemehl.
Berühren Sie das Sägemehl nicht,
können Sie sie gratis haben.
Einfach gut schwingen, jawohl!
* Lachen *
Sie müssen die Beine höher
hinaufschwingen, nicht wahr.
Schauen Sie mal die Bremsspuren an,
die es gegeben hat! Unglaublich.
Dass das so ein Erfolg
wurde, ist schon ...
... ist schon etwas Schönes.
Die Kasse am Sonntagmorgen
beim Vorverkauf ...
Es war unglaublich.
Man erzählte mir, wie die Leute an
der Kasse teilweise wütend waren,
wenn es ausverkauft war.
Einmal wurde sogar eine
Kassiererin angespuckt,
aus purer Wut.
Oder einer habe gesagt: "Engagiert
diesen Emil nie wieder!"
"So kommt man ja nicht
mehr in den Zirkus."
Da habe es Szenen gegeben ...
Eine Kassiererin hatte
einen Nervenzusammenbruch
und musste ins Spital
gebracht werden.
* Lachen *
Ich sitze zwar nicht
gern zuvorderst.
Ich habe immer Schiss,
wenn die Ponys kommen.
* Lachen *
Ich machte keine
gefährlichen Sachen.
Nur einmal sah ich eine Gefahr.
Ich hatte den Schiss in den Hosen,
es hätte dumm ausgehen können.
Sehen Sie überhaupt nach vorne?
Sonst sagen Sie es,
dann stehe ich auf.
Schau her!
Ich sah den Tiger im Käfig.
In dem Moment sah ich,
dass das Tor des Käfigs,
das normalerweise immer zuschnappt,
etwa 2-3 cm offenstand.
Ich dachte, wenn der es
mit den Pranken berührt,
öffnet sich das Tor, und
ich bin allein hier drin.
* Lachen *
Ich habe das gemerkt und
einfach ruhig weitergespielt.
Das ist ja nicht möglich.
Hallo, hallo? Wo sind
Sie hereingekommen?
Haben Sie auch Loge?
Ich bin mit dem Bus gekommen, dann
haben sie mich hier vorne ...
Oh, der Hut ist
noch dort drüben.
Ich musste noch einmal beim Tiger
vorbei, habe den Hut genommen
und bin noch nie so schnell aus dem
Käfig gerannt wie bei dieser Nummer.
Ich haue ab! Hier
muss es doch raus ...
Ich sprach Louis Knie an: "Hey,
wisst ihr, dass das Tor offen war?"
Er meinte, das könne passieren.
Ich sagte: "Ja, kann passieren. Was
mache ich, wenn der reinkommt?"
"Dann nimmst du einen Bock und
musst ihm einfach entgegengehen."
"Dann bekommt er Angst vor dir."
Ich sagte: "Danke schön.
Heb mal so einen Bock!"
Der ist etwa 30 kg schwer.
Wenn die Zuschauer nach einer
Vorstellung nach Hause gehen,
geht für die Zirkusleute
die Arbeit weiter.
Auch für Familie Knie.
Schon ein Jahr vor dem Jubiläum
proben sie eine neue
Nummer mit Chanel.
Anspannen, gell! Weisst du noch,
was du tust, wenn du oben bist?
Den Körper anspannen, die
Beine auch, alles. Bereit?
Sì. - Uno, due, tre, hopp!
Jawohl.
Sehr gut. Die Beine
hochstrecken.
Dann biegst du dich nach hinten.
Weiter, weiter.
Jetzt habe ich dich nicht
mal mehr gehalten.
Chanel ist nie müde,
sie will immer proben.
Das kann man nicht erzwingen.
Man kann nicht befehlen:
"Jetzt machst du das."
Uno, due, tre.
Jawohl! - Guarda, da sola!
Chanel ist sehr gut.
Dafür, dass sie das zum
ersten Mal gemacht hat,
auf meinen Füssen
zu balancieren.
Das ist eine schwierige Nummer, v.a.
für ein Kind.
Man muss alle Muskeln
anspannen und schnell sein.
Uno, due, tre.
Unsere Kinder trainieren
aus eigenem Willen.
Ob es am Nachmittag
ist oder am Abend ...
Das ist unser Leben, wir
sind so aufgewachsen.
Und man kennt nichts anderes.
Allez, hopp!
(Fredy Knie jun.) Ich gebe
meinen Enkeln, meiner Tochter
oder meinem Schwiegersohn
mit auf den Weg:
Disziplin, Durchhaltevermögen,
Selbstbeherrschung.
Das ist das oberste
Gesetz für unseren Beruf.
Hopp!
Ich erinnere mich, mit einem
Pony gestürzt zu sein.
Kopfvoran ins Sägemehl.
Ich wollte heulen.
Mein Vater nahm meine Hand,
drückte sie ganz fest und sagte:
"Jetzt wird nicht geheult, du kannst
nachher hinter dem Vorhang heulen."
Das hat mich schon geprägt und mir
gezeigt: The show must go on.
Géraldine ritt auf ihrem
Pony, und wenn es stieg,
bekam sie manchmal einen
Schlag ins Gesicht.
Sie ging dann raus und weinte
erst hinter dem Vorhang.
Schon mit drei Jahren
wusste sie, wie es läuft.
Mein Grossvater hat es mir gesagt,
meine Mutter hat es mir gesagt.
Wenn ich manchmal ein bisschen sauer
wurde, haben sie immer gesagt:
"Dem Publikum gegenüber
darf man nie etwas zeigen."
Manchmal aber lässt sich das
Scheitern in der Manege
nicht verstecken.
Es ist klar, dass
man enttäuscht ist.
Man kommt nicht jubelnd raus,
wenn etwas nicht klappt.
Ein Artist ist immer ehrgeizig
und ist schon etwas muffig,
wenn es nicht klappt,
wie man gerne möchte.
Bist du bereit?
Du weisst, dass ich das nie wollte.
- Jetzt kannst du nicht mehr zurück.
* Heitere Zirkusmusik *
Schau, Lampenfieber hat
jeder, das gehört dazu.
Aber sobald du da draussen
stehst, ist es wie weggeblasen.
* Drollige Musik, Applaus *
* Peitschenknall *
* Applaus *
Bravo! - Nie wieder.
Es war gut.
- Die machten nie, was ich wollte.
Das sind Tiere.
- Wozu probt man dann stundenlang?
Etwas Geduld, das kommt schon.
- Nichts kommt.
Ich gehe nie wieder da raus.
* Triumphale Fanfaren *
* Applaus *
Wir sind Familie Knie. Wir
leben davon, da rauszugehen.
Ich nicht. Ich passe
auf unser Geld auf.
Wenn's dir nicht passt, kannst
du einen Stock dazustecken.
Meine Grossmutter Margrit
schaute sehr aufs Geld.
Und das war auch wichtig,
denn unsere Grossväter
waren alles Künstler.
Das waren keine Manager. Und sie
war natürlich eine Geschäftsfrau.
V.a. wurde sie eine.
Auch weil sie jeden Abend
selbst an der Kasse sass.
Das ist heute noch so, und
so war es auch beim Knie.
Frau Margrit hat die Moneten,
die Finanzen durchschaut.
Es waren immer die Frauen,
die die Kohle hatten.
* Bellen *
Die Frauen hatten nicht nur
die Finanzen im Griff,
sondern waren auch für den
Haushalt verantwortlich.
Die angeheirateten Privaten gingen
bei Knie nicht in die Manege.
Frauenpower gab es nicht so.
Die Frau musste eher
an den Kochherd.
Das war so, fertig, Schluss.
Darüber hat man
nicht diskutiert.
Ausnahme: das Nummerngirl.
Was heute undenkbar ist,
war früher ganz normal:
Eine Frau verschönert den Übergang
von einer Nummer zur nächsten.
Lotti ist ein ganz
tolles Nummerngirl.
Sie ist eigentlich klein,
aber sie war sehr keck.
Sie war ein wenig die
Seele des Zirkus Knie.
Ich hatte irgendwie einen
Gang, der gut ankam.
* Zauberhafte Klaviermusik *
Wenn ich etwas gemacht habe,
habe ich es gern gemacht.
Dann wurde es zur Gewohnheit,
das Nummerngirl.
Dann haben wir es halt mal
17 Jahre lang gemacht.
Lotti Nock war mit ihrer Familie so
lange mit dem Zirkus Knie unterwegs,
dass die Beziehung heute
noch ganz eng ist.
Fredy junior lässt sich ihren 90.
Geburtstag nicht entgehen.
Wir kommen zur Hintertür herein.
Hallihallo! Schätzchen!
Alte Dicke!
Dick bist du nicht, Schätzchen.
Absolut nicht.
Du könntest sogar noch
das Nummerngirl machen.
Von hinten. - Auch von vorne.
Uh, ich darf beim
Schätzchen sitzen!
Hoppla.
Ich darf das vielleicht
gar nicht so laut sagen,
wenn ihre drei Kinder hier sitzen,
aber Lotti ist meine zweite Mutter.
Das war sie immer.
- Das war schon immer so.
Er ist unser vierter Bruder.
Unser vierter Bruder.
- Der uneheliche.
Der uneheliche.
Ja, Blödsinn haben wir
viel gemacht, gell?
Wenn wir Zeit hatten,
haben wir in der Garderobe immer
ein wenig Karten gespielt.
Und Mary-José hat reklamiert.
Sie sagte: "Heilig...
Und wer hilft mir?"
Dann sagte Fredy:
"Hilf dir selbst,
dann hilft dir Gott."
* Geheimnisvolle Klaviermusik *
Die Menschen stehen auf der
Tournee des Zirkus Knie
heute noch im Zentrum.
Aber früher waren noch mehr
Tiere dabei, z.B. Elefanten.
Es war eigentlich zu erwarten,
dass wir irgendwann aufhören.
Es war mir bewusst. Ich
habe es einfach verdrängt.
Und es ist klar:
Wenn es dann so weit ist, wie
fühlst du dich? Scheisse.
Das war natürlich eine
einschneidende Entscheidung.
Uns war schon bewusst,
dass die Leute die Elefanten
vermissen würden.
Ab dem Jahr 2016 war es
nicht mehr angesagt,
mit so grossen Tieren
auf Tournee zu gehen.
Auch wenn sie vorher
jahrzehntelang dabei waren.
Dressiert vom einen
Familienzweig der Knies.
* Drollige Musik *
Mein Vater war von seiner
Statur her ja ziemlich fest.
Die Leute kannten ihn: Rolf
Knie mit seinen Elefanten.
Ich fand es auch schön, denn
er hat sich langsam bewegt
wie die Elefanten.
Er war nicht hektisch, er hat
irgendwie eine Ruhe ausgestrahlt.
Und das passte zu den Elefanten.
* Majestätische Musik *
Sehr viel Geduld,
das ist die Hauptsache
bei jeder Tierdressur.
Und natürlich Freude
und Kenntnis.
Er hat sich stärker für die
Elefanten interessiert.
Das war vielleicht auch
aufgrund des Äusseren.
Und sein Körper war ...
Er war immer eher
der Elefanten-Knie,
und ich der Pferde-Knie.
* Drollige Musik *
(Franco Knie jun.) Er hat viel
über die Elefanten erzählt.
Als Kind habe ich zugehört,
aber nie verstanden, warum
er mir das erzählt.
Heute muss ich sagen: Er hat
wohl innerlich schon gehofft,
dass ich irgendwann zum Zirkus
komme und das übernehmen werde.
* Majestätische Musik *
Wenn der Zirkus Knie in
Neuchâtel gastierte,
trotteten seine Elefanten
jeweils durch die Stadt
und badeten im Neuenburgersee.
Eine schöne Erinnerung
für Franco junior
und seinen Sohn Chris Rui.
Du musst dir vorstellen:
Jetzt geht hier ein Elefant.
In dieser engen Gasse.
Er nimmt hier die
ganze Bepflanzung mit
und reisst etwas von
den Bäumen herunter.
Hier hast du Hunderte
Leute, die nicht begreifen,
dass sie aus dem Weg müssen.
Das war eine Herausforderung.
* Jazzige Blasmusik *
Wir sagten den Leuten immer:
"Nie an die Wand stehen."
Es gab immer Elefanten, die
den Po an der Wand kratzten.
Der macht dich platt, wenn
du dort stehen bleibst.
* Drollige Musik *
Ja, ja.
Das waren immer schöne Momente.
Das war immer ein Highlight.
Es war eine schwierige
Entscheidung.
Wir haben nicht wegen
Tierschützern aufgehört,
wir hätten weiterfahren können.
Ja, schon. Aber der Druck auf
den Zirkus wurde immer grösser.
Und die Tierschützer
wurden immer aktiver.
* Pfiffe, Rufe *
Früher transportierte der Zirkus die
Elefanten in einem Güterwaggon.
Das war ganz sicher
nicht tiergerecht.
* Düstere Klänge *
Aber Knie kaufte schon früh
spezielle Transportfahrzeuge
für die Elefanten.
Also gegen die Haltung
der Elefanten bei Knie -
solange sie
mitgeführt wurden ...
Das war absolut tiergerecht.
Wegen des Schweizer Tierschutzes
musste der Zirkus Knie
also nicht aufhören
mit den Elefanten.
Aber es gab noch ein
paar andere Gründe.
Ein Grund ist natürlich,
dass der Asiatische Elefant
vom Aussterben bedroht ist
und deshalb nicht mehr
importiert werden kann.
Das war mal ein Grund.
Und auch ... Sicher mal ...
Wir hatten immer sehr hohe
Ansprüche an die Haltung.
Die Städte, die Plätze
werden immer kleiner.
Es wird immer alles
komplizierter, alles wird teurer.
Und somit war das
die Entscheidung.
* Melancholische Klänge *
In der Schweiz sieht man im
Zirkus keine Elefanten mehr.
Aber andernorts schon:
am Zirkusfestival
von Monaco z.B.,
wo sich einmal pro Jahr die
ganze Zirkuswelt trifft.
Demandez le programme!
Gegründet wurde dieses Festival
von der Fürstenfamilie.
Deshalb kommt sie natürlich
auch zur grossen Show.
Fast noch wichtiger
als die Vorstellung
ist für die Familie
Knie der Tag danach.
Denn dann treffen Knies
Prinzessin Stéphanie ganz privat.
Mary-José und Fredy sind
meine zweite Familie.
Das ist mehr als Freundschaft.
Das kann man nicht erklären.
Ich liebe sie von ganzem Herzen, und
wir waren immer füreinander da,
in guten und in
schlechten Zeiten.
Das ist es, was zählt.
Wir sind schon seit einer Ewigkeit
mit der Prinzessin befreundet.
Ich traf sie zum ersten
Mal, als sie acht war.
Sie kam mit ihren
Eltern in den Zirkus.
Fürst Rainier ist und war
immer ein totaler Zirkusfan.
Er hat das Zirkusfestival vor
43 Jahren ins Leben gerufen.
Es gab schon zwischen den
Eltern ein inniges Verhältnis.
Ich kannte Grace Kelly auch.
Wenn man vor dieser Frau stand,
bekam man fast keine Luft mehr.
Man kriegte den
Mund fast nicht zu.
* Zauberhafte Klänge *
Prinzessin Stéphanie ist die Tochter
von Grace Kelly und Fürst Rainier.
Eine Freundin der Familie Knie
und ein grosser Fan des Zirkus -
gerade weil Tiere auftreten.
Für mich gehören Tiere zum
traditionellen Zirkus einfach dazu.
Dafür würde ich mich
auch einsetzen.
Sonst ist es nur eine
Show, ein Kabarett.
Ein Zirkus hat eine Manege
mit Sägemehl und Tieren,
aber es muss gut gemacht werden.
Gut gemacht bedeutet aber immer,
dass die Tiere auch
artgerecht behandelt werden.
Am Anfang des letzten Jahrhunderts
nahm man gerade im Zirkus
nicht allzu viel Rücksicht
darauf, wie es den Tieren geht.
* Düstere Klänge *
Geht man 100 Jahre zurück,
ging man noch davon aus,
dass Tiere nicht einmal Angst
oder Schmerzen empfinden können.
(Fredy Knie jun.) Man hatte
Affen mit Kleidchen,
Hunde mit Röckchen usw.
Und die Leute fanden das toll.
Niemand dachte, das sei blöd.
Die Zeiten haben sich verändert,
die Ansprüche der Tierhaltung
sind viel grösser geworden.
Dass man früher Wildtiere als
Clowns in der Manege zeigte,
war damals der Zeitgeist.
Heute ist man sich bewusst, dass
das die Würde des Tiers verletzt.
Auch Fredy junior brachte den
wilden Tieren früher Dinge bei,
die in der Natur so
nicht vorkommen.
(Originalkommentar) Auch
wenn Zeila noch so tobt -
India versucht krampfhaft,
oben zu bleiben.
* Verspielte Xylophonklänge *
Es ging dort natürlich
auch darum,
welche Macht man als Dompteur oder
Dompteuse über diese Tiere hat.
Man konnte zeigen, wie man ein
wildes Tier bändigen kann.
* Energiegeladene Blasmusik *
Raubkatzen kann man so vorführen,
dass es ihrer Art entspricht.
Aber man kann sie nicht unter
den Bedingungen halten,
die im Zirkus auf der Tournee
zur Verfügung stehen.
Das ist einfach völlig
gegen die Natur
und gegen die Bedürfnisse
dieser Tiere.
Das Publikum fand sich damit ab.
Ich habe niemanden gehört,
der gesagt hätte:
"Ich will keine Elefanten
und Raubtiere,
sonst komme ich nicht
mehr in den Zirkus."
Ich finde einfach,
das Wichtigste ist,
dass das Programm
sehr vielfältig ist.
Vielfalt und Abwechslung haben
schon immer zum Zirkus gehört.
1934 setzten die Gebrüder Knie ihre
Manege zum ersten Mal unter Wasser.
Das war eine riesige,
bombastische Show.
Es hatte dadurch schon
eine Art Hollywood-Flair
mit diesen Tänzerinnen.
Es gab Synchronschwimmerinnen
und diese Wasserfontänen.
Es gab so - paff -
eine riesige Fontäne.
Ich glaube, da fielen den Leuten
fast die Augen aus dem Gesicht.
Wegen des unternehmerischen
Risikos dieses gewagten Projekts
gingen die Wogen auch
intern ziemlich hoch.
Ich denke, so in den 30er-Jahren
begann sich abzuzeichnen,
welcher der beiden Brüder - Karl
oder Friedrich - Oberhand bekommt.
Rudolf war schon gestorben,
und Eugen hatte keine sehr starke
Rolle im Zirkusunternehmen.
Es ging also wahrscheinlich um einen
Machtkampf, wer das Sagen hat.
Mein Grossvater, Friedrich,
war immer sehr sparsam.
Karl hatte natürlich
immer etwas die Tendenz,
auszuschweifen und zu
viel Geld auszugeben.
Dann waren Meinungsverschiedenheiten
vorprogrammiert,
die es in einer grossen Familie
halt auch gibt. Das ist so.
Verdammt noch mal! - He!
Der spinnt doch!
- Nicht so laut!
Nimmst du einen Cognac, Schatz?
Ja, wenn wir ihn uns
noch leisten können.
* Bellen *
Es ist Karl endgültig zu Kopf gestiegen.
Was meint er, wer er sei?
Er hat die Mehrheit
im Verwaltungsrat ...
Weil er Eugen betrogen hat.
- Das hatten wir schon 100-mal.
Weisst du, was dieser Spinner will?
Eine eigene Pantomime. "India"!
Mit 50 Artisten, die er aus
Indien herkarren will.
Der ist doch nicht bei Trost!
Das kostet ein Vermögen.
Dieses Jahr fuhren wir
mit seiner Idee gut.
Das Unterwasserprogramm ist ein Erfolg.
Du wolltest es nicht.
Halt, halt! Ich sagte "von mir aus",
wenn wir nicht alles selbst machen
und das Bassin aus
Deutschland mieten.
Aber bei "India" will
er alles selbst machen.
Er träumt von einer Ausstattung,
die alles übertrifft.
Wir sind doch nicht in Amerika.
- Hast du ihm das gesagt?
Natürlich. Ein Wunder, dass
du es nicht gehört hast.
Aber ich kann sagen, was ich will,
auf mich hört sowieso keiner.
Natürlich ist es ein Risiko.
Andererseits: Machen wir
es auf eigene Rechnung,
verdienen wir auch mehr - wenn
es die Leute sehen wollen.
Ja, "wenn"! Wenn, wenn, wenn.
Ich fresse einen Besen,
wenn die Leute kommen.
Die wollen in den Zirkus
und nicht nach Indien.
* Entferntes Elefantentröten *
Als Karl ein wenig den
Grössenwahn hatte,
und weiss der Teufel was
aus Indien kommen liess,
und das Publikum wollte
das nicht sehen ...
Das hat uns fast das
Genick gebrochen.
* Fröhliche Zupfmusik,
Peitschen, Elefantenröhren *
Und? - Du hattest recht.
Wie viel haben wir eingenommen?
- Das willst du nicht wissen.
Doch, auf den Rappen genau.
Du hast die Leute gesehen.
Weniger als gestern.
Wir müssen froh sein,
wenn jemand kommt.
Das ist nicht nur wegen
der Wirtschaftskrise.
Wir sind schliesslich
in der Schweiz.
Ich habe es gestern
durchgerechnet.
Bald können wir keine
Löhne mehr zahlen.
Dann müssen halt Karls
Aktionäre Geld einschiessen.
Für etwas hat er ja diese AG.
Du weisst genau, dass
die das nicht tun -
in derart unsicheren Zeiten.
Dann muss er das Loch stopfen.
- Mit Geld, das er nicht hat?
Er hätte halt auf
mich hören sollen.
Wenn kein Wunder passiert,
müssen wir am Ende der Spielzeit
Konkurs anmelden.- Nein.
Karl muss Konkurs anmelden.
Wir haben noch etwas Geld.
Was willst du damit sagen?
Ich wäre nicht der erste
Knie mit eigenem Zirkus.
Aber im Moment geht es immer noch
um den Schweizer Nationalcircus.
Wäre es nicht an der Zeit, mit Karl
zu reden? Der Familie zuliebe?
Mit dem, der hinterrücks das
Ruder an sich gerissen hat?
Der dieses grössenwahnsinnige
Projekt durchgestiert hat?
Der genauso wenig mit mir redet
wie ich mit ihm?- Ja, mit dem.
Wenn er etwas zu besprechen
hat, soll er zu mir kommen.
Er weiss, wo mein
Wohnwagen steht.
* Entferntes Lachen,
unheilvolle Musik *
Margrit wusste:
Wenn einer die beiden an
einen Tisch bringen kann,
dann ihr Sohn, Fredy senior.
Kick den Ball! Kick!
Ja, kick!
Ja, brav!
Du bist mir einer!
Das wird sicher klappen.
Wetten wir?
Wenn du lange genug
probierst, sicher.
Fredy, hör mal, du weisst,
dass dein Onkel und dein Vater
seit einer Ewigkeit nicht
mehr miteinander reden.
Das muss sich ändern
und zwar sofort.
Sonst kannst du diese Nummer
nie in der Manege zeigen.
Vater kann doch zu ihm gehen.
- Vater kann gar nichts.
Ich dachte, vielleicht bringst du
deinen Onkel zum ersten Schritt.
Wiesoll ich das anstellen?
- Weiss ich auch nicht.
Aber es ist sicher einfacher, als
dem Pferd Fussball beizubringen.
* Dramatische Klaviermusik *
Fredy senior brachte das
Pferd zum Fussballspielen -
und die zerstrittenen
Brüder zum Reden.
Knies haben es immer
wieder geschafft -
auch wenn es mal eine
Krise gegeben hat -,
dass der Zirkus
überleben konnte.
Ich würde behaupten, das
hängt damit zusammen,
dass die Grossfamilie
ganz enge Bande hat,
dass man die Krisen
intern ausdiskutiert hat,
immer wieder versucht
hat, einen Weg zu finden.
Aber auch damit,
dass immer wieder
Familienangehörige
ausgeschieden sind,
entweder etwas ganz
anderes gemacht haben
oder einen neuen Zirkus
gegründet haben.
Margrit Knie, die hier in der
Mitte ihrer Familie steht,
hatte zwei Söhne und
vier Grosskinder.
Diese vier Grosskinder - Cousins
- waren als junge Männer bereit,
den Zirkus von ihren
Vätern zu übernehmen.
Fredy,
Rolf,
Louis
et Franco Knie.
Den vier jungen Knies flogen die
Herzen des Publikums nur so zu,
v.a. die der Frauen.
Aber hinter den
Kulissen krachte es.
Es gibt Meinungsverschiedenheiten,
die man lösen kann,
und das ist auch gut so.
Und es gibt in Gottes Namen
auch Meinungsverschiedenheiten,
die man nicht lösen kann.
Dann muss man sich trennen,
dem Geschäft zuliebe.
In der Manege merkt man das den
vier Vollblutartisten nicht an.
Aber es war klar:
Nicht alle vier Grosskinder
Margrits ziehen am selben Strick.
Und irgendwann zerreisst das
den Zirkus - und die Familie.
So ein Unternehmen
braucht zwei Chefs.
Dort gab es vier.
Man musste die
Chefabteilung halbieren.
Denn im Prinzip braucht es
nicht mehr als zwei Chefs.
Das war ja bei Knies immer so.
Louis ... hat nicht
funktioniert.
Er konnte sich nicht in den
Familienbetrieb einordnen.
Er wollte selbst entscheiden
und wollte durchboxen,
was er richtig findet.
Und wir müssen
Kompromisse eingehen.
Das ist wie in einem
anderen Unternehmen.
Er hat das nicht gemacht.
Dann wurde es schwierig.
Deshalb kam es dann
zu dieser Trennung.
Das war vermutlich eine
sehr harte Entscheidung,
die auch einen gewissen Zwist
in die Familie gebracht hat.
Und das tut natürlich weh.
* Verführerische,
exotische Musik *
Mit seinen Elefanten-
und Raubtiernummern
begeisterte Louis
Knie das Publikum.
Trotzdem wollten ihn seine
beiden Cousins und sein Bruder
aus der Geschäftsleitung der
Schweizer Nationalcircus AG
ausschliessen.
Er entschied, sich
selbstständig zu machen.
Das hat er dann auch gemacht.
Er ging nach Österreich und
eröffnete dort einen Zirkus,
den sein Sohn jetzt weiterführt.
Es ist über 20 Jahre her, dass
Louis senior nach Österreich ging
und mit seinem Sohn,
Louis junior,
den österreichischen
Nationalcircus übernommen hat.
Ich rede nicht gern
über persönliche Dinge.
In grossen Familien gibt es immer
Meinungsverschiedenheiten.
Einer möchte es so,
der andere so.
Ja, es war natürlich
eine schwierige Zeit.
Ähm ... Sich zu trennen von der
Familie, vom Zirkus und allem.
Aber das war leider die
Entscheidung meines Vaters.
Und es war so, dass
ich noch jung war,
ich war damals 18.
Und ähm ...
... musste natürlich mitgehen.
Dass ich nicht darüber
reden will, ist nicht,
weil ich mich schäme,
darüber zu reden,
aber ich will niemanden
schlechtmachen.
Es ist nie schön, wenn man sich
mit dem Bruder nicht versteht,
aber wir sind charakterlich
so verschieden.
Er ging jetzt seinen Weg, und
ja, das gibt es im Leben.
Louis senior hat
in seinem Zirkus
immer wieder mit finanziellen
Problemen gekämpft.
Sich mit der Familie
wieder zu versöhnen,
war aber nie ein Thema für ihn.
Ich glaube eher, dass
die Situation so ist,
dass die anderen sich eigentlich
melden müssten und sagen:
"Komm, wir vertragen
uns wieder!"
Ich bin nicht schuld
an der ganzen Sache.
Wer schuld ist an der
unschönen Trennung,
sehen beide Seiten
unterschiedlich - immer noch.
Ich habe mich gut mit
Louis verstanden.
Aber er konnte nicht
mit dem Geld umgehen.
Deshalb mussten wir uns trennen.
Denn er ist ja in Österreich zwei-
oder dreimal pleitegegangen.
Und das wollten wir bei uns
einfach nicht erleben.
Er hat immer gehofft
und gewünscht.
Er sagte immer: "Bald
wird es wieder besser."
Er hat den Zirkus immer gepusht.
Er war in einem Traum und
hat immer weitergeträumt.
Irgendwann hat es geknallt
und es war vorbei.
Louis senior macht heute
keinen Zirkus mehr.
Und sein Sohn Louis junior führt in
Österreich seinen eigenen Zirkus.
Auch ein anderer
der vier Cousins
tritt nicht mehr im Unternehmen
seiner Vorfahren auf: Rolf junior.
Er ging ja 1983 und sagte:
auf unbestimmte Zeit.
Er ging seinen Weg, wir sind
nicht im Streit auseinander.
Er wollte einfach
etwas anderes machen.
Er hat auch gern immer
wieder etwas Neues gemacht.
Er hat nicht gern lange
dasselbe gemacht.
* Rasante Brassmusik *
Auch als er noch im
Zirkus Knie auftrat,
machte Rolf immer
wieder etwas Neues.
Rolf hatte sogar das
Zeug zum Fussballprofi.
Mein Bruder war natürlich
der grosse Fussballstar.
Mein Vater war so was von stolz,
dass er Fussball spielte.
Rolf ist gut, was?
- Ja, sehr gut.
In jungen Jahren konnte er sich Rolf
schon gut als Fussballer vorstellen.
Deshalb hat er ihn
auch immer gepusht.
Fredy junior hingegen
wollte immer Zirkus machen.
Die Leidenschaft für
die Pferdedressur
hat er von seinem Vater geerbt.
Du bist allein drin, der
bleibt stehen und ist brav.
Nein, er bleibt nicht stehen,
wenn man ihn nicht hält. - Doch.
Dann geht er zu den Kamelen.
- Das spielt keine Rolle.
(Fredy Knie jun.) Mein Vater
war mit mir viel strenger.
Die Disziplin beim Fussball
wurden meinem Bruder vom Trainer
oder der Mannschaft vorgeschrieben.
Ich musste die Disziplin
natürlich vom Vater akzeptieren.
Fussballprofi wurde
Rolf dann doch nicht
und auch Clown wollte
er nicht ewig bleiben.
Ich bin jetzt 35, und es ist einfach
noch zu früh, um zu wissen,
dass meine Schienen bis an
mein Lebensende gelegt sind.
Wieso soll ich nicht mal etwas
mehr Risiko auf mich nehmen
und auf meinen eigenen
Beinen stehen?
Rolf ist halt ein Künstler und
arbeitet gerne einfach für sich.
Er ist gern auf Mallorca,
malt, wenn er malen will,
und wenn er nicht malen
will, malt er nicht.
Und deshalb hat er sich ...
... ist er einfach aus dem
Familienbetrieb ausgetreten.
Das zeigt aber, dass wir eine
Familie sind wie alle anderen.
Es ist nicht immer alles
wunderschön und rosig.
Und wie viele andere Familien
rauft sich auch Familie
Knie immer wieder zusammen.
Und jetzt geht es darum,
nach jeder Vorstellung
für die Jubiläumstournee
zu trainieren.
Bei dieser Nummer von
Maycol und seinem Bruder
hätte eigentlich auch die
kleine Chanel mitmachen sollen.
Am Anfang müssen die
Kinder diese Sachen
auf eine spielerische
Art ausprobieren.
Nachher können sie
selbst entscheiden,
ob sie weitermachen wollen oder nicht.
Es muss ihnen Freude machen.
Wenn etwas nicht funktioniert,
kann man das bei einem
Kind nicht erzwingen.
* Anschwellende
spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Die Geschichte der Dynastie Knie
war aber immer auch geprägt von
den Ereignissen rundherum.
Der Nationalsozialismus, der in den
30er-Jahren in Deutschland aufkam
und die Welt in einen
Krieg stürzte,
bedrohte auch den Schweizer
Nationalcircus in seiner Existenz.
Ich weiss, dass es für
unser Unternehmen
einfach sehr schwierig war.
* Bedrohliche Klänge *
(Mann) Adolf Hitler, Sieg Heil!
Sieg!
Was ich davon
weiss, ist einfach:
Während des Weltkriegs machten
sie Circus der Nationen,
das war der Titel.
Sie hängten alle
Nationalfahnen auf.
Sie hatten deutsche Artisten.
Diese wollten die
Fahne Hitlers zeigen.
Mein Onkel sagte:
"Kommt nicht infrage!"
* Löwenbrüllen *
Grüezi, Herr Schulz.
- Gnädige Frau!
Beobachten Sie die Vögel?
Wollen Sie die auch
noch dressieren?
Sagen Sie: Wo ist die
deutsche Flagge?
Alle anderen sind da,
nur die deutsche nicht.
Doch, natürlich haben wir die
deutsche Flagge aufgehängt.- Wo?
Dort. - Die kleine da?
Das ist nicht die deutsche Flagge.
Das ist die der Marine.
Das ist auch Deutschland. Es
hat auch ein Hakenkreuz drauf.
So, Herr Schulz, jetzt gehen Sie
bitte wieder an Ihre Arbeit.
Die Zuschauer lieben Ihre
Raubtiernummer.- Frau Knie.
Meine Raubkatzen sind harmlos
gegen die deutschen Behörden,
wenn sie denken, man
wende sich gegen sie.
Herr Schulz, wissen Sie, den einen
ist das Hakenkreuz zu klein,
den anderen zu gross.
Das dort ist ein gutschweizerischer
Kompromiss. Damit basta.
(Franco Knie sen.) Ich
weiss, dass wir sagten,
das Hitlerkreuz komme nicht.
Das hat mir der Onkel erzählt.
Er sagte: "Das kommt
nicht infrage!"
Die Artisten haben das
in Deutschland gemeldet.
Dann kamen wir auf
die schwarze Liste.
Wir hatten es sehr schwer.
Wir waren sogar eine
Zeit lang gesperrt.
Von einem Land, das ...
... unser Nachbar war.
Das ist eine Geschichte, die man
sich in der Familie erzählt,
die auch in den Programmheften immer
wieder niedergeschrieben wurde.
Inwiefern Knies wirklich auf einer sog.
schwarzen Listen standen,
kann man heute nicht mehr
wirklich verifizieren.
Aber es war klar, dass man
nicht mehr einfach so
Arbeitskräfte aus dem
Ausland haben konnte.
Der Zirkus Knie war bei der
Auswahl seiner Artisten
plötzlich ganz stark
eingeschränkt.
Dazu sorgte der Krieg dafür,
dass auch die Pferde des
Zirkus in den Dienst mussten.
(Fredy Knie jun.) Damals hatte
mein Vater Stuten und Wallache,
keine Hengste. Ab da
sagte mein Vater:
"Ich kaufe nur noch Hengste,
dass sie mir im Fall
eines weiteren Weltkriegs wenigstens
die Pferde nicht wegnehmen können."
* Düstere Klänge *
(Fredy Knie sen.) Für
meinen Bruder und mich
kam eigentlich die schwerste Zeit:
Wir mussten alle Raubtiere töten,
weil es kein Fleisch für
unsere Raubtiere gab.
(Fredy Knie jun.) Ich weiss, dass
wir Raubtiere töten mussten.
Mein Vater sagte: "Bevor ich
sie verhungern lassen muss,
müssen wir sie einschläfern."
Die Leute mussten ja
mit Marken einkaufen.
Sagst du in der Metzgerei: "Ich
brauche 7 kg Fleisch pro Raubtier",
schauen sie dich blöd
an, ist ja klar.
Somit mussten wir
selbst Nummern kreieren
mit wenigen Tieren.
Wir hatten fast
keine Tiere mehr.
(Rolf Knie sen.) Das Schöne war,
dass wir während des Kriegs
viele Briefe vom
Publikum bekamen.
Sie fragten uns an, ob
wir Futter nötig hätten.
Sie schickten uns
ein Pack Zucker
oder stellten uns altes
Brot zur Verfügung,
in der Meinung, dass
das den Tieren guttut.
Das hat uns sehr gefreut.
Nicht genug damit, dass der Zirkus an
allen Ecken improvisieren musste -
mitten im Krieg wurde Familie
Knie auch privat hart getroffen.
1941 ist dann unser
Vater gestorben.
Er hatte ja - wie alle wussten -
die Pferde, das Technische
und das Artistische geführt.
Also mussten natürlich mein
Bruder und ich einspringen.
Zum Glück war ihre
Mutter Margrit noch da -
für sie und für den Zirkus.
Als mein Grossvater starb,
schrieb sich meine Grossmutter auf
die Fahne: "Ich muss weitermachen."
"Ich muss unterstützen."
* Treibende Klaviermusik *
(Franco Knie sen.)
Grossmutter Margrit
war wahnsinnig wichtig
für das Unternehmen.
Sie hatte die ganzen
Kontakte nach aussen,
mit Politikern,
Geschäftsleuten, Behörden.
Sie hatte gute Kontakte, damals
sogar mit General Guisan.
Man fragte sich damals: "Spielen
wir, spielen wir nicht?"
Denn man musste
plötzlich verdunkeln.
General Guisan sagte
zur Grossmutter:
"Margrit, ihr müsst das Volk unterhalten.
Es braucht das."
"Es ist umso wichtiger,
dass ihr jetzt spielt."
Bramante, hier fehlt
das Tischtuch.
Ich weiss. Ich
habe es gewaschen.
Der deutsche Gesandte war
heute in der Vorstellung.
Eben. Ich sagte, er solle
auf ein Glas vorbeikommen.
Ich hoffe, er kommt auch.
- Das hoffe ich auch.
Es darf nicht sein, dass wir keine
ausländischen Artisten mehr kriegen.
Wenn die Deutschen das
wollen, ist es so.
* Klopfen *
Ah, Frau Knie!
- Herr Stadtpräsident.
Guten Abend.
- Schön, dass Sie hier sind.
Ja, es war wieder mal
ganz, ganz toll.
Ein Bier, wie immer? - Ja, gern.
Margrit empfing in ihrem Wagen
nach der Vorstellung
immer illustre Gäste.
So!
Ich habe gehört, General Guisan
sei auch schon hier gewesen.
Er schätzt es v.a., dass wir
das Zelt abends abdunkeln.
Und dass die Soldaten nur 1 Fr.
Eintritt zahlen.
Ihnen fehlen sicher
auch Artisten,
die zum Aktivdienst
eingezogen wurden.
Schweizer Artisten
haben wir noch genug.
Die Parterre-Akrobaten, die Sie
heute Abend gesehen haben ...
Fantastisch!- ... dürfen ihren
Aktivdienst bei unsleisten.
Im Gegensatz zu vielen
unserer Stuten,
die für den Transportdienst
eingezogen wurden.- Ist nicht wahr!
Sie sind um jeden froh, der einen
Beitrag leistet.- Guten Abend.
Ist das nicht diese Schauspielerin?
- Lotti Häfliger und ihr Mann.
Also:
Auf den Zirkus Knie!
- Und auf die schöne Stadt Bern.
Prost. - Prost.
Ja, Prost.
Wenn es Ihnen recht wäre, kämen
wir nächstes Jahr gern wieder.
Ja, das würde uns freuen.
Die Leute können etwas
Ablenkung brauchen.
Und es wäre schön, wenn wir zu
den gleichen Konditionen ...
Ja, ja ...- Herr Stadtpräsident,
entschuldigen Sie mich einen Moment!
Herr Köcher.
Herzlich willkommen im Zirkus Knie.
- Die Freude ist ganz meinerseits.
Was darf ich Ihnen anbieten?
Eine Stange?
Lotti, das ist Herr Stadtpräsident.
Lotti Häfliger. - Ja. Komm!
Ja. Herr Gesandter.
Herr Stadtpräsident.
Bei Margrit fühlten sich
die Gäste immer wohl -
unabhängig von ihrer Gesinnung.
* Leises Stimmengewirr *
Vielen Dank für die Einladung.
Das war ein sehr schöner Abend.
Das freut mich, dass
es Ihnen gefallen hat.
Dem Programm fehlt schon etwas
der internationale Glanz.
Wegen Ihren Behörden dürfen
wir aus dem Deutschen Reich
keine Artisten mehr verpflichten.
- Ja, ich weiss.
Ihre beiden Söhne haben schon
bei mir vorgesprochen.
Wohlerzogene junge Männer.
Und sehr talentiert, wie ich höre.
- Sie arbeiten auch hart.
Viele Stunden jeden Tag.
- Ja, das glaube ich gern.
Der Führer hätte die
Reitkünste Ihres einen Sohnes
ja schon längst gern
in Berlin bewundert.
Ja, anno 33, ich weiss.
Aber mein Mann selig wollte
ihn nicht gehen lassen,
weil er ein Problem mit
dem Meniskus hatte.
Am Knie - ausgerechnet.
Das hat der Doktor
gesagt, nicht mein Mann.
Ja, wie dem auch sei.
Vielleicht ergibt sich ja
diesen Winter eine Gelegenheit
für Ihre Söhne, in
Berlin aufzutreten.
In Berlin?
Meinen Sie? - Ja.
Berlin.
Excusez, ich will ja
nicht unhöflich sein,
aber wird Berlin nicht immer wieder
von den Alliierten bombardiert?
Es herrscht Krieg.
* Bedrückende Saitenklänge *
Dann wäre ein Auftritt in Berlin
ja nicht ganz ungefährlich.
Sich mit dem Deutschen
Reich anzulegen,
ist für den Zirkus Knie auch
nicht ganz ungefährlich.
Ein Auftritt vor dem Führer
würde sicherlich helfen.
* Schwere Blasmusik *
Wie reagiert Margrit jetzt?
Schickt sie ihre beiden Söhne
tatsächlich nach Berlin,
damit der Zirkus wieder Artisten
aus dem Ausland bekommt?
Im zweiten Teil erzählen
wir, was Familie Knie
mit dem grossen Charlie
Chaplin verbindet.
Seine Tochter, Geraldine, kommt heute
noch jedes Jahr in eine Vorstellung.
Auf der Tournee wird die
ganze Zirkusfamilie
von einer furchtbaren
Nachricht erschüttert.
Ja, das ist das Schlimmste -
nicht nur in dieser Saison.
Das ist das Schlimmste ...
... das allgemein
passieren konnte.
Die Familie Knie
muss Abschied nehmen
von einem langjährigen
Mitarbeiter und Freund.
Gleichzeitig laufen
die Vorbereitungen
für die Jubiläumstournee
auf Hochtouren.
Und die Nerven liegen blank.
Ja, aber ich will keine Verzögerung.
Heute ist Montage, und fertig.
All das im zweiten Teil
von "Dynastie Knie - 100
Jahre Nationalcircus".